hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
dem etwas späteren konnte das ist total
komisch weil mein handy gerissen ist und
da sind jetzt mehrere punkte und ist
auch egal bei instagram hatte die
angesehen dass man hin die am ersten mai
gerissen ist weil wir das einfach runter
gefallen ist erstmal entschuldigung
dafür dass dieser kontakt jetzt heute
montag kommt und nicht am sonntag dass
sie ganz einfach daran ich habe gerade
englisch lk abitur geschrieben saß von 9
uhr bis 13 uhr in nethen wird von 9 uhr
bis 14 uhr also fünf stunden in den
gleichen raum wo wir nicht die fenster
aufmachen durften weil sonst die mädchen
meint mal so kalt und da war so scheiß
luft und war ich bin sogar ohne spaß ich
habe auch nur vier stunden geschlafen
hatte nach dem sieg weil wir
wahrscheinlich an
wenn man also in meinen augen gucken wir
gar nicht an aber ich schwitze müssen
wir jetzt heftig heißt ich wollte nur
sagen einfach leute zurzeit läuft nicht
alles nach plan hauptprojekt bei mir es
war also eine kleine zusammenfassung ist
jetzt gerade einfach hier im auto und
war gleich nach hause läuft gerade ich
alles nach plan bei youtube also was
heißt also es läuft aber hauptprojekt
ist alvaro
ganz einfach ich würde ja gerne richtig
viele mode reviews machen und pvp und
mit anderen auch noch und turbulentesten
würde ich auch bringen jetzt kommt dann
einer von hinten egal magath ein freund
von mir darum mit mir geschrieben hat es
ist halt einfach zurzeit so ein bisschen
schwierig zeit für youtube und für
schule und für freunde zu finden weil
ich schreibe zwar nun schreibt nur vier
abiturklausuren aber dafür muss man halt
für jede richtig lang lernen ich hab
halt das glück dass die bei mir alle
sieben tage auseinander sind also ich
schreib quasi jede woche ein und kann
dann immer sieben tage durch dafür
lernen deswegen produzieren wir waren
auch im voraus sind da nicht in so viele
kämpfe verwickelt etc das ist halt alles
zurzeit so ein bisschen eher
provisorisch wie ich die ganze zeit
mittlerweile über brücke ich wollte euch
nur sagen
ich bin dabei das alles zu regeln als
abitur läuft bisher gut deutsch war
richtig gut deutsch und englisch
englisch war auch gut also die von euch
die es eventuell auch englisch lka die
tour geschrieben haben schreiben immer
welche klasse genommen ob ich habe die
mit obama genommen dass der halt die
figur des jahres ist und sonst hält man
sich gar nichts machen ich wollte nur
sagen dass halt zurzeit alles mit abi
lernen sehr sehr stressig für mich ist
hat noch ein komplett formel-1-auto
kraft einfach hinten allerdings hoch na
gut ich muss ja aber langsam wächst
steht zu hause am tisch ich wollte euch
nur ganz kurz ein kleiner überblick
geben weil ich wusste wirklich nicht was
ich als kontakt machen sollte weil für
sowas so lange planen und dann irgendein
thema aussuchen ich wollte doch mal
wieder machen dass ich einfach irgend so
ein aktuelles thema nehmen und meine
meinung dazu sage aber dazu habe ich
zurzeit einfach wirklich keine zeit welt
wirklich pausenlos fürs abitur lernen
bin weil mir das echt wichtig ist dass
ich da was vernünftiges reise weil es
ist halt quasi das was worauf man zwölf
jahre gewartet hat mit in die schule
gegangen ist deswegen die
kameraperspektive vorstellt ich muss mir
also in seiner halterung kauf lässt es
hier so hin machen kann dann kann ich so
kam die loks machen schreibt mir meine
kommentare wie das pendel würde wenn ich
so fahre egal wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat so etwas improvisiertes aus
dem auto das eventuell öfter haben wollt
ihr seht im hintergrund die sonne
scheint wunderschön schreibt meine
kommentare lassen wir wertung da tut mir
leid und heute kommt trotzdem auch warum